today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza it's a premiere a
pizzeria you know you don't you don't
even know what's going on sometimes and
then BAM you're eating pizza well you
can do that at gray block 18:11 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach in Los
Angeles gray block get that hitter
today's guest is an artist who I've
wanted to have in since I started
podcasting
he's from Baton Rouge Louisiana and
currently lives in Atlanta this man does
music but this man does so much more
ladies and gentlemen mr. Boosie badass
[Music]
gucchi thanks for coming in man how long
you in LA for a couple of days I got to
get back for my daughter birthday but
I'm coming right back yeah yeah and when
you come out here are you shooting a
film right now what are you doing out
here right now I'm just I'm just really
hustling you know I meet with people
about films I'm doing videos and you
know it's the corona so every every week
or two I'm picking picking States to go
to it and get money in and spread my
wings
these next two weeks is gonna be LA
California to hold Northern California
in Southern California and uh whenever
cuz you I feel like you work harder than
anybody man right right every time I
turn on your Instagram you like is going
down tonight Club percoset Club
whispering something somewhere right
somewhere where does that work ethic
come from it comes from hustling it
comes from not having and hustling see
uh most of the people who successful in
the game who got successful long term
they was hustlers in the street first a
lot of them you know do you think your
hustle changed uh I mean obviously you
were younger before you got incarcerated
you think your hustle changed its Martin
this one always was a hustler hustling
like a doll hustler run myself to delft
you know I was 22 with them you know
living cause mansion things like this or
prison made me smarter you know it made
me smarter as far as music right as far
as other business opportunities I read I
read music books and I always had hustle
so I just went together you know but the
prison helped my house do you think if
you hadn't have gone to prison like um
do you think there's a better chance
that you might not have lived
like like were you going at a fast rate
of life yeah yeah yeah yeah probably
that's had at all I mean I remember I
mean I grew up in Louisiana you guys had
it all I mean you guys were like right
you guys were kings and I mean you're a
king now but you guys yeah because
that's fast for a young man that's a
fast life yeah it came fast you know but
it didn't seem like it seemed like it to
other people but I had been in the game
so long I just when I got my breaking
peeked I just peeked I was everywhere
but uh it's just a blessing man it's
just a blessing to be where I'm from him
you know to jump out like I jumped out
and now you know bad roads we and as far
as rap wheel will we'll hug ya know um
when you were in prison to you because
you were at Angola right right
did you ever get to go to the rodeo
there yeah I went to the rodeo do you
really yeah I went to the road never I
went to the rodeo my my last year that I
went to rodeo they went crazy they let
you perform or anything like that or not
ain't let me perform they just you know
they just really I think got the crowd
out there you know knowing [ __ ] was
gonna be out there so I had got real
cool with the one and uh it was
beautiful seeing all those women and you
know it be a beautiful sight you meet
all the rodeo ladies that come to watch
ya then ladies that come to watch the
rodeo you know ladies big ladies the
rodeo women be big light pants with that
buckle in them yeah yeah
make you wanna Rajas yeah would you stay
and watch the events yeah hell yeah
that's what you know you gotta go get
that make make the inmates go get the UH
the [ __ ] funny they make the inmates go
get the thing off the top of the wildest
bull huh and you might win five hundred
to a thousand dollars so you know
inmates who don't have [ __ ] they going
up Dan Trotter they don't give a damn
what that boar do to him that was one of
my favorite thing when they grab a
bullet thing off the heat like capture
the flag kinda yeah yeah
did you ever get out there now I enjoy
watching to do did they have a bull
riding too or was it just kind of like
this sort of thing yeah not a bull
riding yeah so well whoever stay on the
longest wins yeah yeah they got all that
yeah we had a young guy in here who's
like the world champion of bull riders
okay and uh just seeing his body type
he's liked his body kind of bends right
in the middle some people longer up top
longer legs but his body bends right in
the middle he's kind of perfect size for
the way he rides on the bull
is there anything that you miss about
being in uh in jail yeah I'm a CC murder
man yeah I mean because all of his
appeals are up now - yeah but God is God
power for me you never know how it's
gonna work yeah they might free evidence
what they've been fine and they should
just be let go you had two other guys I
think I read two of the people that
testified against him took back their
testimonies right so it's a bad
situation but it's a it is God working
you know that's what I miss the motions
my friends in there Pro that I wish
you'd come home you know that's what I
miss the most you know I don't I don't
you know I miss I miss my friends yeah
that's what I mean man you know did you
guys with their times in there I mean
obviously I've never been to jail but I
wouldn't mind maybe doing a couple
months or something but I don't want to
do like a long time you know what was
there ever time is it kind of fun like
being able to just be around your
friends and stuff or you spend a lot of
time by yourself it depends on if if
you're in protective custody or if
you're in population you know most
rappers go to PC they stay in a Cell
they hold time in jail is that what you
had no I don't do it oh hi everybody
yeah I've always kind of been a man of
the people and no matter what yeah like
you can't you know you drive you crazy
in this cell yeah you know a lot of
people just be afraid but uh you know if
you're a rapping you can if you can if
you can live on the streets you can live
in jail you can survive in the hood you
can survive in jail because it's just a
hood it's all the same thing you're just
right so if you get surviving and now
you get surviving
and penitentiary and uh you know I had a
suite and pay attention man I really
yeah I had my last my last couple years
my first year I was on first two and a
half I was on death row so I was in a
Cell a one-man cell the whole time so
yeah the day I beat my murder charge I
was laid off death row and I had a
choice whether go to protective custody
or to population with 150 people in the
dark and you went in there yeah
was it fun kind of what you got a never
was it a release oh yeah it would it
would it was sweet man you know contact
visits like I said general could you
have women come visit yeah yeah man and
then the first time I went to visit
everybody went crazy in the child house
so the warden hurricane you know he
looked out for me him and vanilla they
gave me my own vision and [ __ ] 70 inch
flatscreen
my own movies my own chef my own picture
camera man you know so visit was my
everything you know so I was I was laid
out man I was laid out not and I
appreciate it they just told me stay out
of trouble and they were laid me out
yeah I remember when you came out man I
was really excited I come I've been a
big fan for a long time and uh I
remember I put a tweet on because it was
right before Easter and I remember I put
a tweet on Twitter and it said he
Easter's come early he has risen that's
what I put yeah and how did how do you
feel like like social media I feel like
like I a lot of us were conditioned on
social media like we got it as it was
coming out you know we learnt like it
became slowly a part of our lives you
kind of have this unique way about you
on social media that it's just sometimes
it's too real like it's so real it's
real er than like a lot of people
everything is very it's organized it's
planned you know they talk to somebody
do I do this what I do but you [ __ ]
live you come from like a different
place with it like it's such a real
slice of what your life is like
I do you feel like that's because you
came into social meet like you missed
that whole conditioning where we all got
slowly conditioned to it you suddenly
had it does it make sense basically you
know I've been like this a long time
like I just busi doing what boots do
saying what boots say acting the ass on
all my DVDs if you look back I've been a
clown it's just it's a platform where I
can show it yeah and you know cuz
everybody if you if you don't if you
don't see that side of me just think do
see is the worst shooting [ __ ]
even did all this [ __ ] you know you got
you know if you let other pit not the
music if you let other people judge it
yeah if you let other people judge
you're gonna take from it is boosie
badazz with a ruler ooh yeah he'll kill
him murder right right right but a lot
of people don't get to see that I'm a
father I'm a friend you know a regular
guy a regular guy so that helps me in
some ways
yeah helps people a different edge you
cuz yeah if you hear busi badass you see
some of the pictures you think oh man
this guy like I was nervous our big baby
was in here and he said oh boo see a
gangsta do you know and he's a real
gangster but he really but he's a real
gangster that's the thing that people
don't realize about boo see like that's
what he said and I was like huh
he's like yeah boo see is one of the
last gangstas but if you look through
all history yeah every gangster had a
personality yeah from all the gangsters
the biggest gangster Al Capone
now couple every every gangster had a
personality just came out with the peek
around the people he loved
yeah you know I'm saying and uh that's
just basically it with me like when you
see me on the interview like I'm myself
right I'm myself but you know how I was
raised when I go places when I go to
clubs when I'm when I'm around the
public you know I was raised I was
taught not to smile with [ __ ] right
you know my dad you you go play city you
a [ __ ] don't smile with [ __ ] you know
a [ __ ]
that shows the form of somebody might
want to try right you know it's not that
I'm practiced looking hard no it's just
a habit yeah
it's something no it's habit winner you
know when I and you know is know feel
you know and I'm gonna bring that same
kind of violence if they go that way so
I can't be in public all you know me
clown and that's when I'm at home yeah
but not in public is not like that cuz I
don't want people to just come try you
try me like this so in public is like
yeah come on I got a gun let's do it
yeah you know so is it uh I've heard you
talk about moving out of Baton Rouge and
um you know I know that you know you had
instances with like the the District
Attorney's errant stuff trying to attach
charges to you and right you know there
was a lot of what seemed like from what
I've heard uncomfortableness between you
and the law enforcement there right
maybe not exactly they're cops but the
over the overseers of them um what is it
about Atlanta that is makes life more
comfortable do you think Atlanta was a
big superstar you know I don't stick out
like a sore thumb yeah yeah 20
superstars you know you
yeah bigger any better yeah they had you
they had c-murder Silkk the Shocker
Master P and they had that tiger that's
in the cage outside of the P Mack Center
right right and most of them from the
wall yeah man rules is different from
New Orleans Baton Rouge is you know
Birmingham to Atlanta yeah yeah you know
as far as racism as far as everything
you know that's the deep south right so
uh and Atlanta is different though and
Atlanta is different you know it's black
power yeah no I did I was on stage there
a couple months ago I said damn it
seemed like Black History Month started
a city yeah that's for the senior yeah
is this black power you know black
people own thing black people have well
you see uh we have wealth you see a lot
of black policemen you see a lot of you
know and and the police showed me love
man it's crazy man it's like it's like
they want to help you you know I can't
say that for everybody in Atlanta right
but as far as the offices I didn't ran
into they want to see me price will man
right I was in my rolls-royce one day
I'm slipping I'm at the light I'm
smoking I'm high as [ __ ] I'm slipping
man I look to the side clear windows
Coley is looking at me he say
[ __ ] he telling me to roll out on one I
know is he telling me the road I don't
know one did not pull off right I got it
right right he say roll out what up man
man put that [ __ ] out man going here man
then what he told me put the [ __ ] out
man he going here man take care of your
damn fan smoking weed out here like this
man that [ __ ] was like man my heart just
dropped
so that was you know that they always
see me and be like they just give it up
to me bro and there's more understanding
they understand bro they understand that
you know I'm not even coming to this
city to be a problem they understand
that I'm a businessman right you know
and wealth to changes things man I
noticed even just growing up in like we
would go to Atlanta sometimes to see the
sugar bowl or to visit an aunt that I
had that lived there occasionally we
would drive up to Atlanta and it's a for
me just as a you know me just a regular
white person pretty much but it was the
first city that I saw that had like
black wealth in it you know like in like
a lot of I'm talking a lot of money like
the car will pull up to a place and
you'd be like damn and black people
would get I would be like what the [ __ ]
yeah you know it was just it was
different it was something that you know
I grew up in a small town it was black
and half black half white but and we
didn't have any wealth bus but you had
just never seen that before you know
like when I was growing up the only
wealthy black Americans that I knew were
like Dallas Cowboys you know what I'm
saying like there was a couple people
but you didn't see it you never saw it
in your face I don't feel like until
Atlanta right right right they they set
a stage for a lot of [ __ ] cuz I'll
because when I went down and uh I'm a
season ticket holder underneath so
you know I've been going to NBA games
and many and uh the first time I saw you
know with a triple-a floor seats
you know 70% black you know you know and
that made me smile you know yeah you
know black black black black women you
know successful you know and we're nice
big boys season and that's a change of
culture yeah you know it's not like that
Louisiana you know it's not like that
you know it's not like that other places
is you know the stuff I see with the
black people out here me it makes me it
makes me proud be proud to be black
yeah yeah I can imagine it's totally
different I mean I'll just have my own
perspective but there is something
that's it's exciting to see when you see
oh if this culture has money they can
have a comfortable existence
right right right and I don't mean not
have any judgment I just mean right I
feel what you're saying but uh I feel
what you're saying they got a ghetto
everywhere they got a ghetto everywhere
slums everywhere yeah it's just when
more people show show value and welt it
makes other people want wealth and that
cuts out the [ __ ] right you don't
say
you mean like it inspires younger people
desires it inspires people yeah because
everybody has a role model yeah and the
role model is Daman ones with the most
money so uh you know is more role models
oh yeah I think it's like definitely
more more role models in Atlanta than a
lot of places you know yes especially
for I think for black kids you know I
mean just cuz like even if you think
like you know when I was growing up just
like you would see people come to the
school and they would say okay it's
gonna be career day at school somebody's
dad's gonna talk about their career and
it was always used like if it was a
doctor it was a white dot you know what
I'm saying like if it was right but now
I think especially in places like
Atlanta you have that it's different you
know like people coming it's all types
of people come and have a career and
that gives a kid sitting there like oh I
can have this right it gives them a
different aspiration
what do you see like going on out here
today man this [ __ ] is wild you know uh
do you see a difference between the
protesters and the people looting or do
you I think it's all well deserved you
know it's been going on way before these
these people who everybody flashing who
did black people who deny murdered yeah
it's just they got caught with the
cameras the camera phones adds a lot to
it when I in 89 90 our neighborhood hero
got killed by the police just jumped on
the hood and [ __ ] smashed him it'd
been going on
it's just now we got him right there as
soon as something happened they out
right so we got him if that if they
didn't have those camera he would be
dead Glen flaw was right if they didn't
have those phones that blessed us now
they see what they've been doing for 20
25 years and do you think I've saw a lot
of that anger you think it's built up
from people that have seen I've seen
other people be killed that never you
never hear their name again and so a lot
of that anger just builds up yeah I
think I think I think it's a hidden
built up over the years yeah and we had
a time right now where everybody pissed
off this was the wrong time yeah you
know people out from their jobs people
at home yeah
okay harder being a known people tired
of being an ox t were tired of being at
home you know our presidents crazy yeah
you know it's just it's just you know
it's nice it wasn't the time for this
yeah especially for black people yeah
you know we've been kicked you know I'm
gonna post some on Instagram in two days
I've been holding it but I'm talking to
Trump I'm talking to everybody you know
black people should be paid like the
Indians
it's our race been through more [ __ ]
than anybody why hasn't no [ __ ]
presidents a while the black of man
while they're not compensated you know
why I haven't no but we does wealth been
taken from us we was hanged our wealth
was stolen from us millions we're still
our kids our
on a date black family should be
compensated why no [ __ ]
president never said that even Obama
yeah I don't get it
yeah I don't get it the Indians we damn
Indians India's deserve photo black he
must be blind
that's true I won't know why I
[ __ ] promoter not a promoter
I'm thinking about my bag I won't know
why all these people who interview the
president's Holly peepee behind these
damn cameras
why y'all never eggs D got mr. mr. Trump
do you feel the black should be
compensated for what they've been
through in their life I don't know why
no president no bags dick yeah we've
been [ __ ] over in it
we've been [ __ ] over chick today's
hanged Oh made to also do a plays and
stuff I didn't want to do remember that
bro is bad bro like the blacks they've
been through it more than anybody bro
any race will tell you that nobody has
been done like the blanks we deserve to
be compensated every [ __ ] month
yeah every [ __ ] month black
families should be compensated so do you
like what do you even know what an
amount like that would look like I don't
know but if you got trillions for walls
you got trillions for us we don't make
up that much of the population yeah we
don't make over half of it you got money
for us if you got money for walls they
shred money up and throw that [ __ ] away
every year you can give it to those
blacks who bent down and kicked and
hanged how hard he did say hang a lot -
but I feel you though yeah because that
was a hanging yeah yeah when you when
you hang somebody you put something on
their neck and you cut off the oxygen
till there's no life left that was a
modern day hanging ya put you put
something on somebody Nick and you
squeeze it I got this in the post
I'm posted on it that was a hanging when
you when you hang somebody you put
something on a neck until there's no
response yeah it was no response for two
minutes that's an extra hanging
after they hanging they do this boom
they take them off you let him hang for
two extra minutes that was a modern day
he should get the death penalty
yeah do they have the death penalty I'm
wondering that state third degree murder
that ain't [ __ ] he won't he won't do
five years you know what's the top
degree you can get first first degree
and what is manslaughter manslaughter is
in some states that carry five years as
some states that carry 20 and some
states and that [ __ ] don't carry nothing
that's probation you get probation that
[ __ ] if you're first then he'll police
officer
yeah like you know like and then able to
go even arrest the other police - yeah
that's crazy
if like like it still like that girls
say you're four black people go kill
somebody and all of them in the car all
of them get that murdered show you know
I don't care one shot I don't care if
one all of them get that murder charge
yeah for the beat even if they was in
the car
you know not on camera they're on camera
right you know so it shows racism also
it shows racism towards cops that's why
I don't I don't I don't feel sorry that
they burn this [ __ ] down I think
they actually do burn this [ __ ] down
till we get our conversation yeah that
would be nice every family and be like
we burn this [ __ ] down today we get
conversation hey [ __ ] it you got to be
worth if like I say about 5,000 a month
every family yeah do you feel like one
of the biggest things that plagues the
black community is just not having to
find the finances I don't know man I
think I think we need to build our own
economy that's why I think we can we had
a move right now with the rise and [ __ ]
we can build our own economic we need to
get the billionaire's together y'all
should own more your [ __ ] we should
build our own economic make our own
music yeah we should build out to our
own banks yeah you know same thing what
they did with black Wall Street back in
the days and it's all Oklahoma
yeah another thing all day what happened
they burned it yeah they burned it down
took everything you know we're in the
black dough black people all those black
people worth millions of dollars that
will be billions today right
so you probably need to start our own
economy man economic our foods our
Amazon and everybody get together make
it and make our own economic you know
you know I'm say even if we got it even
if we got to get front it from somebody
else
yeah we can start we can start our own
economic our own state you know and and
yeah see how much they missed us and we
can we could put a real hole in their
pocket yeah cuz we run the fashion we
run all this [ __ ] you know black people
running a fashion a lot we want we want
we we run even white people want to look
like us okay real [ __ ] especially if
they're 14 or 14 50 years old you know
they didn't know how you wanted to be
ice cube armor writing Ice Cube on my
cheek before I go to school bro that's
how much I wanted to be I wanted to be
like ever ever will you see that that
fashion with that rap shit' yeah it
attracts you man even if you don't know
the music yeah you want the jacket you
want the Michael Jackson Sox hat you
want you know yeah so we can make it's
just it's the owner fuels to ownership
that's what it is yeah so I was saying I
was thinking I thought I was talking
about this with my probe scrim guy about
who I do Pro screaming with you know
it's a gaming company and uh first we
will have to buy the land that's what we
have to do first we would have to buy
the land you know the guys they got a
lot of cheap laying out then we have to
buy land man we have people doing it
Tyler Perry has that huge place in
Atlanta he has that huge studio yeah
that place is a movie right but I'm
talking about for life right I'm talking
about sending our kids to school sending
our kids making making them
business-minded right so be rich not
just the film I'm talking about a life a
whole state of life lovely black life
livelihood yeah our own [ __ ] to me
everything yeah and we will hurt the
world man we would hurt the world we
would hurt the world and we and once we
do that we probably can start our own
laws cuz they got [ __ ] towns
they got hick towns in these states
their own they all
land that they police station are they
own laws yeah and we would have we buy
the [ __ ] land and we have our own
laws it's just black people don't don't
don't don't want to put it together like
that that's how I feel
we always against each other instead of
with each other do you think that that
could start to change some do you think
that is getting better I think we're
gonna get strong enough yeah because cuz
cuz I've been going places everywhere
I've been going people you know like my
black brother like brother like I just
feel like we're getting stronger well
you know people starting to care more
about our black people yeah and we're
starting to care about us more yeah we
you do a good example I feel like I mean
with the chips the Cologne I mean
everything you try to I feel like lead
by an example of your work ethic and the
way that you create your own
infrastructure for yourself you know
everything is that has to do with you it
feels like runs through you and that
gives you control over it do you where
do you feel like you got that kind of
business that kind of business mine
because I have a problem with Hollywood
- it's one of the reasons why I started
are in the studio right because so we
can make our own stuff I don't like I
don't like a company that I don't even
know these [ __ ] own in a part
of me telling me how I can look how I
can behave right um and we've prospered
man like we sell out tickets I mean I
sell we did I did a world tour last year
you know I'm not bragging but we did it
on our own because I don't like somebody
own is I don't like somebody own in a
piece of me I don't like somebody
exploiting me right so I can only
imagine kind of the level that that
feels like on a to a black person you
know right right a lot of people a lot
of people a lot of people look at my
husband a value you know because I ain't
letting [ __ ] get over me you
know I know
I know what I can do I know you know so
everything I mean I got on the ship
there's not one thing I mean that I
don't have on this ship yeah you know
I'm not no promoter I think I'm not
going to promote your brand clothes you
know and this is on Instagram right
that's a business that's a business you
know I get paid for that but uh nice
I gotta have ownership because uh you
know once you sell it you know I guess
nothing if I won't sell it today and I
guess nothing so I gotta have ownership
yeah that's just how I am in it and I'm
in a position to do that you know I give
money I drop a city every month I'll
marry money I'm independent yeah so you
know I mean I don't got to take a couple
crumbs from nobody cause I'm already
selling eight that's nice isn't it yeah
if it feels good when your chicks coming
to you yeah don't nobody else have to
pay you do you feel sometimes because
this is a side effect of my the way I
operate
I do feel sometimes I feel left out by
the mainstream do you ever feel that
yeah always I always been they've always
tried to put me out of the mainstream
Boosie made it to the mainstream Qaboos
it made it to the mainstream you know I
came out I was 14 you know 15 years old
98 I didn't get on BT - Oh 403 yeah Oh
for so you know I'm talking now I mean I
feel like you've taken on a whole
different I mean it's your up you gotta
understand you gotta understand the way
the way I've came home and turned into
entrepreneur and five six different
things people in higher places people in
higher places don't want me on side of
them I'm a threat to [ __ ]
I gotta help myself by me having
ownership and [ __ ] it's not like that
nobody's gonna help you like that yeah
cuz they could be jealous you know David
you don't get help from [ __ ]
who who can't really help you
you know you're not gonna get that
because they know you're a threat to
them you know and I and I feel like that
in so many ways you know I'm left out a
lot of [ __ ] but I don't dick ride right
you know I don't climb I don't need to
know I don't
anybody else's help you know I don't
need to hang they get to get nothing
yeah if you don't come to me God ain't
God ain't make it for me
that's how I feel so I'm just you know
I'm just I'm just boosting man and they
can't stop it
and once you gotta follow in and once
you got a I got a cult following people
love me that's crazy brah
dude there were times when I even would
get I'll be like I there was a little
blob be honest I didn't love you anymore
bro yeah and I [ __ ] real of you yeah
so bro like you could be loved twice man
like that's how much that's not all you
know what I'm sayin though like that is
how I think that's a sense of attraction
that you have to fans you know is that
they could be like nine then they'll be
like alright yeah the truth is as folks
adapt to this changing world we're all
going to be buying more stuff online
think about the things you've been
getting online a chair and a light bulb
a a tooth brush a butterscotch anything
well if you're an e-commerce seller are
you ready to meet the demands of this
new delivery culture well you can be
ready with shipstation
why shipstation because when you're
selling online you're getting a lot of
orders fast and it can be tough how do
you keep track of who gets what which
shipping carrier should you use are you
getting the best rates
that's why you need shipstation it's the
fastest easiest and most affordable way
to manage and ship your orders ship
station helps online sellers of any size
get orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep customers happy
no matter if you're using Amazon Etsy
your own website shipstation brings all
your orders into one simple interface it
works with all the major carriers USPS
FedEx UPS even Amazon Fulfillment and
right now this past weekend listeners
can try ship station for free for 60
days when you use offer code th e Oh
make sure your business is ready to meet
the
of delivery culture that's the new
culture you can get started at
shipstation
dot-com today support the podcast go to
shipstation comm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Theo
that's shipstation calm and enter the
code theo shipstation comm make ship
happen support the podcast thank you so
much and now back to the episode we've
got a question right here from this
[ __ ] white guy had a question about
Takashi 6-9 actually so the fact that he
just got out of prison from from being a
snitch and everything do you think it's
right that if you know people kind of
like a new song to supporting it it's
like high on the Billboard charts what
do you think the community should just
stop [ __ ] with him altogether
Bobby this is a video he sent in okay I
don't really want I don't really want
comment on Takashi six nine right now
does he remind you of him when you does
he remind you you and you were young at
all nah you know like I wouldn't fake it
like I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't
you know when I was young until this day
I'm still the same person you like I'm
I'm built like that you know so I
wouldn't you know I don't really want
comment on Takashi signai cool cuz uh
you know it ain't worth it you know you
know here you know I don't really want
to comment on like a certain situation I
don't comment on because I'm not nothing
to do he you know right you know even
with you yeah you know yeah I don't like
I'm bushi I don't get no clouds from
beefing with 6:9 bro like that don't
that don't go together yeah like I don't
get no nothing no cool points yeah
and I'm not the mother dude like I'm
serious bro like Nick we fix this Mike
I'm serious
I just want to make sure it's a good
thing you need to come out with him boo
see viagra's bro what about that
working on him hitters but we're gonna
you know because dude I used to get the
ones at the gas station the first ones
that came out with had like a picture of
a horse on the package and they would
make my nose bleed they wouldn't even
make my dick hard yeah and I would keep
taking a man cuz I thought oh maybe I
didn't take enough I'm working on some
she's real herbs bro like ribs be a DS
badass dick pills yeah yeah yeah we
promote them for the younger generation
I'm promoting them for the rapper's
having three [ __ ] at night and gotta
get back today [ __ ] trying to get up
so I'm promoted foot you know for the
travelin man but a traveling man no yeah
you know what I'm talking about the
casino man yeah no dude I think I think
man I never actually hooked up with one
black girl one time but I've always been
a little bit a lot of the black women it
seemed like they [ __ ] back if you try
to [ __ ] them you know like they like
sometimes if you [ __ ] them it seem
like you're [ __ ] them but sometimes
they [ __ ] back a little you know do you
think that uh like they seem like more I
don't know what I'm trying to say are
you saying white women are more
missionary like it's a little more
docile like I feel like it's more like
you petting something you know whereas I
I guess I'm uh concerned not concerned
but uh yeah if I'm having sex with a
black girl then I feel like damn she's
gonna it's more like wrestling like more
like she's gonna really [ __ ] me
you know black girl like to ride a dick
damn that girl like the [ __ ] cuz you
know she'll want you to say I do when I
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out you gonna be like they
got a little dad with him
yeah I got some pride with ya Oh white
girls like to just be slayed and [ __ ]
boo honey you [ __ ] this [ __ ] out yeah I
feel sad me yeah spill a Gatorade on me
spit on me so black girls got a little
pride to where there actually was that
[ __ ] good you know damn yeah really
that's why she was throwing at all you
like that makes me a little nervous I
gotta get out there more thing you gotta
get out there I'm gonna cut up some of
my party man really yeah well I did hear
though that's another thing big baby
said that you had the wildest parties
man yeah
oldest yeah man yeah he said Wilders
brother majani and everything bro yeah
it'd be going down man I'd like to have
a good time but I like to have a good
time and I like fun girls yeah
and I like to see it's really about
showing everybody else a good time yeah
this is fun huh yeah walking around
everybody and just everybody having a
good time yeah about it like [ __ ]
I love you - you know so that's what I
get out of you know yeah that's what I
get out uh there was something you
talked about a little while ago about
like sometimes I noticed even you know
growing up in a poor white environment
like a lot of times they don't uh you
know you feel like you don't you feel
like you don't exist sometimes you know
because there's a there's a lot I feel
like that in and I didn't grow up in
like a redneck place you know I didn't
grow up in like like my mother my mother
was a educated woman you know like she's
a hard worker but we weren't like
country you know like we weren't like
rebel flags or like you know fish that
could we just we're just kind of regular
people you know and sometimes it feels
like when you're in a community in a
poor environment that the hardest thing
about the environment is the environment
itself you know it's your Nate it's your
neighbors even though if they are your
friends they sometimes people don't want
to see you leave people want to see you
change what do you think some of the
tougher thing is in a black environment
that uh that make it the toughest to to
leave it you know to get out uh
something really gotta happen to you
before you leave
cuz when you give money most times
you're not leaving will you and that's
something really happen you know I I had
that problem nice to feel like you know
ain't gonna know what is my city you
know ain't nobody I don't care what's
going on you know and a lot of people
had that frame of mind and it's the
wrong frame of mind as soon as you get
money you gotta go because uh cuz you've
changed the one who wanted to fight you
now he want to kill you right the
policing
didn't know you he wanna arrest you
because people have something to gain by
getting something over on you now right
right right right right you know and you
get hatred from the people who went to
school with you who feel like the head
and when those people shouldn't hate
when they had the same chance as you
right but it's better to go to another
city where you'll get loved you know
duck off in a nice spot and work on your
career because uh I said over me many
times that most people get killed in
their own City and uh you just say you
know it's a dangerous job as a rap is it
we got them I feel like we got the most
dangerous job in the world
yeah because nobody want to kill a
comedian you know nobody I don't want to
kill a comedian nobody thinking I'm
gonna gun this mother nobody yeah if you
don't hit this punch line I'm taking a
sword to this [ __ ]
you know nobody wanna kill a hockey
player yeah that's true man but do you
get scared then putting music out or do
you ever get worried that one of your
past songs created such a like a I'm a
dog you know that that it is that it
might have inspired somebody enough to
be a [ __ ] killer and now they're
gonna come at you don't I'm saying like
giveaway that your music could inspire
like some John Lennon yeah yeah yeah
like you could be the black John Lennon
man that's a good song name black John
Lennon Hey I don't know did he was on a
bicycle and somebody shot him I think I
just hate that uh you know so many of my
fans who come up on my music idea now in
Israel I mean I know in the black
communities just uh I mean this is
obviously just for my perception it's
more it seems more dangerous you know it
seems more dangerous is it exciting
though sometimes when there's more
danger like white white community is you
gonna be fine kind of broadly like
you're gonna have breakfast and shits
probably gonna be okay
you
it's normal it's not exciting it's
normal like violence is normal things
that happen in a hood it's really normal
cuz it's been happening since you were a
kid right so uh you see somebody
murdered at 8:19 all through your life
when you get 17 uh you're not gonna have
much respect for life probably gonna
have different perceptions of things
yeah either you're gonna turn you all
the way away all the way to that's the
perfect thing yeah as in a hit because
you once won one once you watch somebody
get murdered close to you you feel you
can do it even if you didn't it even if
you didn't do it before somebody like
you me yeah yeah that's how that's how
who the babies are like well somebody
takes something you love you feel you
can do it because cuz you've seen it
seen it's right there you know you is
like an automatic yeah you know well
they're right you know that's
interesting so yeah and if that's been
going on for such a long time then of
course that feeling is gonna be in
people yeah yeah like Jenna right I fire
yeah like I fire that's heavy man
that's intense [ __ ] oh we got a video
Nick the two that came in mm-hmm here
comes somebody right here this gentleman
what up [ __ ]
what up do I got a debate for y'all
Raising Cane's a chick-fil-a raising
behind Gang Gang go Tigers
damn duck raising Cain duh what raising
Cain duh takes over damn chicken fillet
raising Shane but you tell me you got a
shoot you told my god no comparison you
tell me you make it through the Atlanta
Airport without hitting the chick-fil-a
showing up at the counter seeing a
beautiful [ __ ] girls that work at the
counter I admit it they got the
best-looking women
that work at the counter you know when I
start eating chicken fillet huh when I
came home from prison flying an airport
yeah oh yeah you fought Delta do you
yeah so I I was raised on raises is no
other chicken finger that was the other
first other chicken thing I never ate
his actions yeah I feel like they did I
still ain't any dead [ __ ] in that land I
looked at it I say no it took my distant
knew raising Cain I looked at it I say
hey I know because I was raised on
raising Cain like the first ones and
Louisan like I was raised up yeah but
dude chick-fil-a man you get that little
chicken sandwich you opened that [ __ ]
up it's in that foil bra that thing
looking at you like a little newborn
baby got that pickle on it I hated bent
over I just know like him saw gas
pickles all right I got them soggy as
pickles ice cream pretty good okay
[ __ ] nuggets too small one of those
nuggets is three McDonald's nuggets not
coming off fire chicken flares up now I
like chicken fillet but they ain't
messing with no raising Cain and there
you go man I think you got it I think
you got your answer man um but what
something else that I wanted to ask you
about oh uh it's a different game now
before you were incarcerated in now the
the rap game does it feel different it
feels softer from religious a listeners
perspective do you feel like it's a
different it's different it's different
as far as music wise it's not about who
rhyming who spitting lyrics through the
heart is as far as that's not about that
just about who made the best song you
got people like now you know the flow in
and all that it does decease that [ __ ]
is mostly deceased
it's just harmonizing now yeah like
Bruno Mars you like him he's just home
yeah yeah I like huh yeah I like Bruno
it's just harmonizing now it's not about
you know people don't have time to sit
down and listen people in their phones
now yeah people used to I used to have
albums with all the lyrics on them yeah
mmm solitary inside and [ __ ] is not
about that no more people don't have
time they just want hear this hook and
vibe they don't have time to even really
listen to what you're saying
most people don't even know what the
rapper's talking on this true
yeah a lot of times so hip-hop has
changed you just got to change with it
do you feel like you could see yourself
have one day having like a some Bala's
or maybe doing that booty Christmas
album come on man oh yeah I did a
Christmas album yes yeah yeah I did I
got a Christmas album out nine it's
crazy it's crazy so man uh music is
power
you know music it was this is what
crossed over racism yeah you know and
people people be talking about sports
and knowledge music music is you can't
leave people can't some people can't
live without music yeah music crossed
over white people except in black people
music yes Sammy Davis jr. James Brown
yeah oh I've been gay and Elvis for the
guy that wrote Elvis Presley songs I'm
not sure who he was but uh some guys out
of Memphis I think that wrote some of
these early hits
Sidney pepper what's his name Sid temper
temper do you think that up but you can
see yourself having a ballad out one day
you get a little bit older you know what
I'm saying yeah I could see I could do
it no but I'm talking weight though yeah
you know yeah I can see it music is fun
to me is it it's fun to me I like to do
it you know like you know I like to do
it you know I like to do it I like to
show my greatness with music I'm just on
the independent level not do you feel
like um like you know I work as a
comedian I've had a it's been a long
road it's been like 17 years maybe
working in the past three years had been
started to be good you know I started to
reap like earnings from my work you know
and sometimes I wonder if it's really
something that I did or do I think that
I just was given a gift you know what
I'm saying do you ever feel like that do
you feel like you're chosen
do you ever feel that about yourself do
you ever yeah everybody everybody is
chosen ones God make people to be the
chosen ones to do certain things yeah
some people you pick to be a boss you
pick to be underboss God pick you for
these things yeah you know everybody not
made to be the man you know you was
picked and God gave you these gifts so
you can you know
were picked simple as that yeah other
people who probably had way more talent
than you but died on the way yeah you
were picked do you want if there was
something else you ever look at another
job and it could be any type of job a
small job a big job a quiet job a loud
job do you ever look at another job and
think oh man that's something you feel
inside like oh that's something that I
would have been I would have liked to do
besides what I'm doing yeah even even if
it wasn't a great whatever I woulda did
I would have ran it yeah my mom always
told me did she really
I ran I've been running my cleat since
three four years old I've been the lead
of the pub my clique and everything this
is the playground at the beginning yeah
sister but whatever I woulda did you're
a leader I would I would have leave yeah
and yeah anybody can tell you in my
project I've been the leader since birth
like so whatever I woulda did I don't
know what it was you know if I were to
play basketball of an appoint go right
you know if I would have been a CEO at a
corporation yeah you know that's how I
feel because I always I know how to
bring people together and I know how to
make people make money too
yeah who was big when I was when I was
in college Taurus bright was big do you
remember him yeah Torres bright scored
77 points yeah him and Chris Duhon yeah
played against each other at salmon of
Slidell biggest thing in the state now I
would like to see that it was the
biggest thing and Taurus was the nicest
guy to man I used to see him in New
Orleans sometimes you worked at the
Sheraton for a while too okay after
basketball okay you watch LSU basketball
now yeah I watch it now my nephew play
fairly sure really yeah if I'd say smart
oh really yes your nephew yeah oh yeah
with him sort of shorts yeah yeah man
he's good bro I thought he did better
the year before I think he'll get back
to doing good yeah I think yeah he did
me working hard right now yeah we don't
we forget him now
yeah you know he just had this [ __ ] with
the NCAA and all a [ __ ] oh yeah that's
right him and coach Wade both had it
yeah Vermont waters was great though
wasn't he you know I'm talking about the
little point guard the lice game yeah
yeah and he plays in Maine now he plays
on like a triple-a team but damn he was
good but I think last year that he used
Devon tape correctly really I think they
had him play in
I don't know if the year before
sometimes they they let him they had him
bringing the ball up sometimes I like it
better when he on the wing yes I feel
like he's serviced he just his skillset
was better I think he's still gonna have
some good seasons though oh that's crazy
man I don't know that was your cousin
yeah um well I just want to correct the
guy who wrote for Elvis Presley that was
black was Otis blackwell
CID temper was a white guy I just wanted
to correct that was black well uh I
always felt like that black people
didn't get scared like I've always felt
like when I was young like I would felt
like sometimes I would get scared and my
black friends would not get scared like
they wouldn't they just didn't have like
the same they didn't feel fear or
something the same way that white people
did is that does that make any sense to
you do you think right because this is a
different upbringing it's a different
upbringing you know most times it's a
different upbringing than y'all house
though
you know you know our weapons are
different right right so if you get beat
by your daddy you know your mama be
chairs with a switch your my all moms be
tired so fighting you uh some that's
that's not [ __ ] right you know we filled
our mothers and fathers more than
anything in the streets that's fun ya
know like yeah that would be a thing man
I would feel like if I got enough I go
to black it up like damn I'm scared and
he's about to [ __ ] that fun and that
was a scary fear you know that because
it's like that you know we go out there
to do this so uh we is different if do
you feel like um do you feel like music
like a lot of music has violence in it
you know it has right energy it has it's
talking about the streets places you
grew up do you feel like that
contributes to like black on black crime
like it contributes to young men you
know it's some in some ways I can't say
that but in some ways but uh it also you
know it also take care of millions of
life
music mogul's and music take care of
millions of black families right so it's
so evens out but it's up here as far as
success it's a way for us to tell our
story right now we make the money that
only the country singers told a stories
on the porch now we tell our stories on
the porch yeah they're just different
right and we can't blame us for telling
our stories because we was put in these
situations right you know this this
country put us in this situation so you
know music made us opportunity to get
good money and get rich and get
respected yeah so uh I was talking to
our life ain't no different than a
country singer talking about what's
going on up on the porch somebody
breaking somebody hot drinking a beer
right hoody whoo that day that
[ __ ] [ __ ] Martin my cousin you
know I'm saying it's just you know he
[ __ ] this good and he got shot yeah so
just just cover the exclamation point
zone you got shot um what was something
from when you were young that you miss
like just being a kid what was something
you missed because I hate getting older
man I hate it bro I hate it man like I
used to miss like I used to miss at
school you would go we remember you
would have a girl maybe you had a crush
on her something and just like how I
like how I behave around her at school
like scared to be bi or just [ __ ] do
I really miss much because it was I
don't really miss the struggle really
you know III I miss I miss everybody
hanging out there and front my
grandmother house you know like family
you know that's what I miss the most are
hanging that's why every time I go to
Louisiana I do the same thing that I did
when I was a teenager yeah throw
barbecues and you know cuz that's what I
miss oh you're all kind of [ __ ] man
you're like I need anybody that does
snowballs yeah like I need yesterday I
miss being that little kid and one one
you know exit I mean I love that feeling
of the bigger
gonna give me $20 $10 yeah that made my
whole week so I go back and I do things
that I always wanted to see you know and
especially to me I'm living somewhat of
my childhood as an adult
right I'm the king now yeah you know I
know how I felt when they're gonna keep
just looking at me you know and he just
stare and I just stare at him I know not
to do that from how that affected me
looking at the big time I'll sue does he
like me I didn't know he just looked at
me right so I was up let me go why are
you looking at me what's up right break
that ice I break that ice I never left
cuz that did one time I looked at every
one of the bosses like that I was just
looking at he was fresh as [ __ ] but he
looked at me like what the [ __ ] and just
turned his head you know and uh that
stuck with me for like four years
because you're thinking what does he
think you know now like who because he
ended up giving me some money I'll cover
years after that but that stuck with me
with big Kenny yeah it stuck with me
brothers I ain't know what he thought
you don't even like me yeah I feel that
so I break that ice with him when I see
them kids doing it I always what's going
on little man yes what up man what's up
man yeah you wanna take a picture come
on yeah you know cuz dim the ones who
read they kill yeah something on a heart
you know yeah and let that change his
mindset then he's not he don't leave
wondering okay how does that man feel
right somebody not except right he
leaves sambusa cool yeah and it's okay
for me to inquire and be curious yeah
without getting shut down
yeah yeah good dramatizing key that's
really yeah um your kids have a
different a different life that your
kids have had a different life than you
had growing up right do sometimes they
don't have the same they don't it's just
and there's nothing you can do about it
because because so much is given to it
it's crazy and that crazy brother they
don't they don't have they don't have
near by the same and you can't recreate
that you can't name ten percent of the
kids under 15 was saving money yeah you
came in
you know because it's different it's
different you need you can't name kids
who you can't name too many you know it
people everything is right here in there
yeah they're not that good for nothing
they want to know if a girl like I'm
it's right there they want to find out
about a job they want to ask something
is right there you know it is different
you know and I feel like that disabled
kids disabled a lot of athletes in the
world because a lot of kids don't want
to go out and play they just want to see
right here
well yeah oh yeah well they got to have
a a fortnight if you was raised in the
80s and 90s you had to be here to be
outside yeah your fun had to come from
outside yeah you had to make it you had
to make it yeah now I got all right here
now now everything is all right here
they look like creatures almost when
they get locked in right right you
didn't have to go really study the
spelling test and all you just pull it
up yeah you know do you is it an
interesting know how you can't recreate
that for them you can't it's like it's
weird once you get a generation of
wealth it's there's something that it
does negatively negatively to the next
generation yes that crazy bro yes that's
crazy I was just watching that on a show
on on American greed what happened to
with some [ __ ] just like that because we
give it to them but we didn't that you
see that's what happened with my with my
a couple of my kids I gave it to him so
two three thousand is not a lot of money
today right they blow through this [ __ ]
that's crazy
you know so I'm raising my mind my other
generation of kids my 19 11 year old
every day I go to work every day I'm in
Atlanta I go to work they gotta get up
and go to work with me if we shooting
videos they gotta have the props they
gotta be working right if this is every
day if they got they gotta check in at
my door at 7:30 yeah this said I'm gonna
make them work for everything right I
paid them $150 a day when they go work
with me nice I told me you stay with
your daddy to someone at seventh there
$17,000 there piece for you and this is
a steal
in their head now that's how you make
money you work that's how you make money
you work right so when they get 16 they
not gonna it gonna be like a sin to ask
me for money yeah they're gonna be so so
on stacking and once you get to see in
those bands take my boys fell in love
with it
my boys they say dad I made $1200 in
eight days out of a trip you know it's
exciting it's exciting but if we just
and just give it to him they would never
know the word it's crazy though innit
crazy because you would think though you
would think they would have the same -
sure it doesn't carry it doesn't it's
really interesting man yeah cuz my
brother and I when we were growing up we
didn't have anything but now my brothers
worked really hard in Baton Rouge he has
a tree-cutting company and uh and now he
has kids they have a different life you
know and it's part of it so he's like
you would have had that of you out here
Ridge cares no I wouldn't be the same
person I would never been a comedian
because I had to be a comedian to defend
myself the only thing I had when I was
young was my words you know like I
couldn't know if we didn't have the
extra stuff but words were mine you
couldn't words I had they came from me
right like anybody could have something
else you could have the new Reebok pumps
whatever you could have all the [ __ ] but
my words were mine you know and so when
it came to humor or words and I said oh
this is my weapon because nobody can
control if I have this or not I wake up
with my words every day right so that's
why I think I got into doing stand-up
because oh this I can do this
know everybody has this but if I master
it then it's like I don't know it's me
showing them I'm gonna show them you
know even if I didn't have some of the
same things look I'm gonna make the most
of what I do have you know my words I
just wish it I just I just wish it would
just carry on I know man it's crazy and
it's almost sad to see it not carry on
because you're watching you yeah but but
they write well it's yeah yeah so it's
like are you the bad influence weird
it's weird like it's weird man like do
they see how hard I'm working
but is she like you know yeah I don't
know it's funny it's interesting to see
if they recognize yeah that's it uh you
watch UFC or no no no but I'm trying to
start my own you got to start watching I
finished on my own backyard or a fight
I'm just going through the lawyers right
Nick in one man he's going through the
lawyers right now bro I got my logo
together yeah it's going through the
lawyers right now we every every place
got across the track so we're gonna be
setting up by training tracks I just got
the steel gate I got the steel gate got
all my paperwork together and I'm gonna
do a five fights in each city $1,250 a
piece yeah the winner gets you 50 yeah
it started out start out that leash
started out in and I'm finna you know it
gonna be my nother YouTube no it'd be
good yeah um what paint gonna be funny
cuz I'm gonna be the [ __ ] commentator
your own a commenter yeah so I'm gonna
be going oh no the [ __ ] over here yeah
how my knee is you gotta get dropped
five times a TKO is five times the only
way to [ __ ] stop is five rounds by
only way to the fight keeps on going
throughout the fifth round if you
haven't been knocked down five times are
you out cold
that's the only way to fight stop you
know some people gonna pretend they are
cold to not get back up though yeah yeah
yo Anne's got you guys dropped five
times
I'll be out cold we go kill it rope
cross the track street bro I like it man
yeah yeah we'll [ __ ] put white Nick
in the one man I'm breathing calmly I'm
ready man like you know you need twelve
fifty fifty that's nice
kick somebody man I go out there now
what if you lose what do you get fifty
you get 250 hopefully a few hundred
Allah bet yeah yeah yeah I'd even lose
for 250 man yeah man get your ass
whooped
that's why I gotta be five times
yeah that's why we struck five times on
your ass out cold
we gotta go there you got I want to be a
referee for some of the match hey that's
hard that's hard did we send it bow we
got to connect with this sheep we got a
cadet let you be a referee clouded [ __ ]
man
or comedian are you our [ __ ]
come on man you not out man get back up
you not out yeah yeah I see you peeking
oh yeah
what about boo see coffins that's the
thing I always wanted to see and I'm
shocked you don't do dolphins yeah like
like going to heaven you know like a
coffin you know I never doubted it
because I feel like you kind of have you
represent a little bit of like this
that's [ __ ] spooky kind of thuggish
elegance don't we call come on man
speakers in the inside somebody just
going straight to heaven bro what are
you gonna do when you go into the ground
he goes all right that might be bad last
question would some I know
[ __ ] white people do some wild
investors was one of the wildest
investments you ever gotten her somebody
tried to get you into my Oh something
wild bro I'm child yeah girl Instagram I
like [ __ ] you a good daddy
let's just have a baby and we not gonna
have no like you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want but me you'll make a cute
baby like no strings attached like I
just want a baby with you you see I was
like did you get it no no because this
will come for money probably I just it
was just too much like we never even
talked to him like we like I didn't
comment on the Instagram like I never
you like we had no she just [ __ ] me up
like I want to have a child with you
like I know you're gonna take care of
your baby I know you don't give a [ __ ]
about what women do I don't care like no
no yeah that's a
an investment bad investment yeah I said
I said no um I don't know what else I
got man I really appreciate your time
man I'm just always gonna fan out and I
really admire your work ethic man
there's times when I don't want to do my
work man and I see you doing I see you
[ __ ] got the red eyed you like all
right you know we it's going down a
night you know boosie badazz we gonna be
there you know Covington Kentucky
Scotland South Carolina wherever yeah it
just never ends mine
I like to find things and if you love to
you you could get them you can get them
you know I'm saying cuz I rapped on the
corner for years for free so when you
tell me you got some money for me it's
hard for me to say no yeah I agree with
these things I got I make I make a
weight I gotta hear you out I wanna just
say that you know like I'm gonna hear us
how would you say do what did anybody
ever offer you money cuz Glen big baby
tell me somebody paid him one time to
hook up with his wife right did you ever
get any [ __ ] like that I feel like that
stuff wouldn't come your way though
really nah people he gave me 4,000 for
my hat right I had a guy gave me like
3,500 give me your head man I got 35
yeah straight to the model in these days
not the same when I just had a little
booster on it but you know you got a lot
of fans you know I've been off of my six
you know I've been out for my six
Ivanoff you've been offered it yeah girl
for me
7,000 damn one girl paid me 7,000 to
have six how long you have to have sex
for certain amount of time or now well
this girl this was backing on this was
four I went to prison she paid me like
7,500 to come back to a mansion into him
she had a big-ass mansion in August she
paid me $7,500 six with it and come to a
mansion was a man in there too or no no
no yeah no man in there
hate me to come that she was [ __ ]
with music too so she she had some money
and she straight came to me out of
concert looking like I got sent in five
hundred for you to get in there yeah and
I did uh I can't really [ __ ] I can't
[ __ ] real real good I can [ __ ] okay I
feel like if it's like around the
holidays or something you know you're
like on a regular time like maybe around
Christmas that's when I really feel like
what you getting a Christmas spirit I
get that Christmas spirit yeah man I'll
do some real [ __ ] around Christmas but
other than that I'm not I'm not that's
not my main thing you know I'm not
really that hit man I send somebody else
in the [ __ ] I come in at the end you
know yeah I'd that kind of cleanup
hitter you know I don't know man I think
that might be all I got man damn I never
thought I'd run out of things to talk to
booth you know yeah but uh but thank you
so much for me well honey y'all be good
I gotta go get me some heat
God [ __ ] the car she mad at me
right now ain't even do [ __ ] she made it
then that's how I do where I'm gonna put
you Dickie all-in-all [ __ ] you
tonight [ __ ] am i I'm a foam finger [ __ ]
oh hey Brooke send me in at the end you
know what I'm saying
[Music]
it's gonna take
a little town for me to set that talk
and breathe and let myself
[Music]